what began as a racist tweet has become
a rallying cry for supporters of US
president Donald Trump at a campaign
event in North Carolina he repeated his
attack on several Democratic
congresswoman some of the crowd started
chanting send her back
[Applause]
now earlier this week Trump had tweeted
that the representative should go back
to their countries despite them being US
citizens Democrats condemned his racist
comments but Republicans have thrown
their support behind the president and
here's part of his speech in which he
goes after the for minority lawmakers
[Applause]
for the hate-filled extremists who are
constantly trying to tear our country
down they never have anything good to
say that's why say hey if they don't
like it let him leave let him leave
they're always telling us how to run it
how to do this how did that you know
what if they don't love it tell them to
leave it let's get more on those
comments at that rally we have here in
the studio DW Zombie NSF and we really
seen this defiant tak attack by the US
president on these Democratic
congresswoman all of them US citizens we
have to reiterate what's going on here
I think it's been shocking for people to
see a US president telling American
citizens to leave the country that is
definitely a first year but the ideology
behind that is nothing new I mean even I
growing up in the US with the Lebanese
last name got told to leave the country
if I if I didn't like it so I think that
has been present and he's picking up on
that he's using that as a rallying cry
on the one hand people are saying it's
racist because he's attacking people of
color here women young congresswoman
with migration background some of them
but not all of them don't forget that
Alexandria Ocasio Cortes who he singled
out is has a background from Puerto Rico
which is part of the United States so on
the one hand it's been called racist on
the other hand it's very political these
women are some of the most vocal
opponents of his doctrine and so he sees
them as a threat I believe and is going
after them because of that one has to
think about the upcoming presidential
race of course and and you know perhaps
to understand a bit of his strategy
looking back at the last presidential
race one of his his mantras that he
would get the crowd to chant was also
lock her up lock her up he was referring
to of course Hillary Clinton in that
case do you see a connection here
there's a very explicit connection here
I think also the crowd sees the
connection they're playing with that the
lock her up chance was still the a major
chant at his rallies until early so a
few weeks ago even he had a rally in
June where they chanted lock her up
about a presidential candidate from 2016
so it's very much geared toward the
election he likes these little sound
bites but there's something a little bit
more sinister about telling a citizen to
leave the country okay I mean I want to
get your reaction also to another part
of his speech because he he talks a lot
about migrants as well reaffirming has
promised to deport millions of
undocumented migrants it has left many
families living in fear of being swept
separated by raids by US Immigration and
Customs Enforcement Agency that's nice
of course DW is Howland Humphrey reports
on that and then I'll get your reaction
thereafter like most parents Rosa
Gutierrez Lopez couldn't imagine being
forced to leave her children but as an
undocumented immigrant her greatest fear
is a realistic one Rosa fled violence in
El Salvador 13 years ago now she's
facing deportation her three children
were born in the US her youngest son
John has Down syndrome and she's worried
he wouldn't receive the same care in El
Salvador and so for the past eight
months she's been seeking sanctuary here
at Cedar Lane Unitarian Universalist
Church near Washington DC living apart
from her children during the week so
they can still attend their school it
was hard telling my kids that I had to
seek refuge in a church I couldn't go
back to my country and leave them here
and I also couldn't take them because I
would be putting them in danger they
could be killed criminal gangs their
recruit children from the age of 10 and
if they refused they killed them Carol
or mutton roses deportation was ordered
after she missed an early immigration
hearing when ice agents tracked her down
they fitted her with a monitoring
bracelet and ordered her to leave the
country
in da SE encontró an Amiga the COS valid
encontraron amiga I may be a friend ask
me what's going on I had to tell her I
was coming to say goodbye I had to put
my children in another school I had to
tell her that I was being deported it
was hard for me like Oh doctor you know
me so well
but I want you to deport me because I
missed a court session that doesn't make
us criminal criminally Reverend Abby
Jarrah man she hoped that ice agents
will avoid entering places of worship
the church is now one of 50 religious
communities offering sanctuary we
decided to become
physical sanctuary congregation driven
by the guiding principles of our faith
and in these times where we see the
current administration engaging in in
policies and actions that threaten the
safety and also the humanity of people
the church has also started an
information campaign preparing
undocumented immigrants for deportation
raids and how to avoid arrest namely by
refusing to open the door for Rosa and
many people like her the threat of
deportation raids has confined them to
living their lives in the shadows of
society everyday activities like buying
groceries or seeking medical care come
with a sense of fear now President Trump
says that Isis set to remove quote
millions of illegal aliens from the
country the reality is closer to around
2000 people without papers and
Democratic lawmakers say that these
kinds of statements are a tactic to
intimidate communities just like this
one let us once again but the community
is not backing down holding vigils to
let Rosa know that they will protect her
even if the Trump administration is
taking a different stance
[Music]
so we see demonstrated there I mean that
fear of being rated by ice the the
customs enforcement agency and
immigration enforcement agency tell us a
little bit more about these rates that
are going on well Trump had announced
that there was going to be massive raids
on starting on Sunday and he built this
up which caused a lot of fear in the
immigration there community of
immigrants in the United States I think
that was partly part of the goal was to
create the sense that America is no
longer welcome to people who immigrate
illegally or even legally at some in
some cases but actually activists who
had prepared for these raids to show
immigrants their rights to teach them
how to deal with a raid that could
violate their rights they were a little
bit surprised that there were so few
actually and what you've noticed is that
Donald Trump is embracing this idea of
the DePorter in chief but actually
deportations haven't significantly
increased they haven't moved anywhere
since Obama was president there was a
decrease after Bush left office but
Obama was known as DePorter in chief and
he was always trying to shed that which
is something that was part of his legacy
that he there was a lot of deportations
under his when he was president and
Trump is trying to embrace that but with
mixed results I mean you can see that it
comes off a little bit as little as a
lot of talk and no action okay so the
rhetoric not matching that action DW is
ami and SF on this story thank you